hi I'm Matt can I built the myspace
application for Android hi I'm Thomas I
view the Schism application for Android
I'm Casey Langan I built the amazon mp3
store for Android so when using some
application after you've tagged a song
you have access to to some other
applications so you can click on myspace
it can open the myspace application you
can click on amazonmp3 and you open the
amazon mp3 application oh that was was
really really easy to to develop so yeah
for myspace we just specified a URI
pattern so that they could send a view
intent to open to myspace profile within
our application the upcoming shows and
whatnot for amazon mp3 you just create a
new intent with a explicit package name
activity name stuff a couple key value
pairs in a bundle and fire the intent so
using on android linking between
application is very easy using paint
intense so it was just so
straightforward as having vain 10
specification and just using it